pas de procès aujourd'hui dans la salle
d'audience du tribunal de vesoul
mais une collecte de particulière pour
les associations caritatives de
haute-saône des vêtements et des
appareils électroniques issus de saisies
lors d' enquête est destiné à la
destruction leur sont remis par le
procureur à l'issue de la signature
d'une convention j'ai l'intention pour
ce qui le concerne les laisser une belle
justice de faire cette opération deux
fois par an minimum
et puis on a mis en place un circuit
plus simple plus court qui permettra aux
associations
elle est directement auprès des
commissariats et des brigades de
gendarmerie lorsque des biens ont été
saisis des biens pour lesquels
effectivement il est impossible
d'identifier l'auteur le propriétaire
des objets et donc la convention leur
permet de récupérer ses biens dans un
délai de huit jours
la croix-rouge dépendent des fonds
européens et de la banque alimentaire
aujourd'hui elle bénéficie d'une
nouvelle source d'approvisionnement
au total ce sont plus de 400 kg de
vêtements en provenance du palais de
justice
on va trier le linge ce qui nous
intéresse
la vente sera prix est remis bas ici au
vst boutique
sinon le reste bon bah ça sera ni donc
recyclage si c'est une aubaine pour la
croix rouge
en revanche emmaüs restent sceptiques
sur l'opération c'est pas un plus pour
email je pense que c'est un plus pour
d'autres associations caritatives qui
sont moins habitués à recevoir des dons
nous il se trouve qu'on a énormément de
donateurs parmi les habitants de la
haute saône et
les objets qui nous ont été présentés
sont quand même des objets de très
moindre valeur avec la signature de
cette convention
cinq associations caritatives de
haute-saône recevront les bonnes oeuvres
de la justice